moi je n'accepte pas que la décision
politique est le choix politiques qui se
fasse en fonction d'un choix religieux
la religion n'a rien à faire maintenant
est donc moi je sais ce que je souhaite
c'est que on n'est pas de femmes voilées
sur des affiches sur les campagnes
électorales officielles
c'est je trouve parce que derrière c'est
un message religieux dont vous ferez une
dérive communautariste que nous ne
pouvons pas accepter donc vous voulez
l'interdire j'ai bien compris
nous nous souhaitons lui imposer la
neutralité religieuse quand on se
présente à une élection eh bien on
respecte cette neutralité religieuse
vous avez un ministre garde des sceaux
en exercice dont le premier sujet pour
les français aujourd'hui c'est la
réforme pénale et qui plutôt que de
s'occuper de ce texte de s'occuper de la
réforme pénale face à la délinquance qui
monte face aux policiers qui sont
agressés il trouve rien d'autre que
d'aller en campagne aux élections
régionales dans une élection dans une
région en plus où ils n'habitent pas
honnêtement c'est lui l'aîné du monde
d'accord mon fils n'y habite pas la
réalité c'est quoi c'est qu'on se moque
du monde
moi je trouve que quand on est garde des
sceaux on est gardée 70% et on va pas se
balader sur les marchés dans le nord où
on pas de calais uniquement pour faire
une chose c'est obligé xavier bertrand à
être soutenus par la public en marche au
deuxième tour voilà la réalité et faire
monter le rassemblement national
ça c'est de la politique politicienne de
la tambouille continuant comme ça il
faudra pas venir pleurer ensuite si en
2022 malheureusement madame le pen est
élue